welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber a Texas man was killed
on the morning of his 15th wedding
anniversary and authorities say it was
all part of a murder-for-hire plot they
alleged the man's wife was involved and
got her boyfriend to kill him the sound
of gunfire on that morning in October
2020 was caught on a nearby ring
doorbell camera
[Applause]
all right so James and Jennifer Faith
they were out for a walk with their dog
in their neighborhood when he was shot
in the head torso and groin prosecutors
say Darren Rubin Lopez was that shooter
Lopez and Jennifer Faith were high
school sweethearts who reconnected
during the covid-19 pandemic Faith
allegedly used a secret email account to
email Lopez even pretending to be her
husband Chapin James is a physical and
mental abuser Lopez told investigators
that those emails are what manipulated
him to drive more than 11 hours to the
Dallas area and kill James Jennifer
pleaded guilty to murder for hire in
February 2022 a year after Lopez was
arrested and charged with killing her
husband Jennifer faith is serving life
in prison as Lopez faces the same
punishment in his current trial the
prosecution laid out Ruben Lopez's
efforts to contact faith in 20 2020 as
well as emails between the two within
days of reconnecting it was clear that
Ruben Lopez was head over heels in love
I know my heart and you still possess it
I love you and that sounds so good when
I say that I think we can also over time
build our own relationship in our own
way neither of us is in a position to
jump into anything crazy yet
but I know I would like to start down
that road with you good thing I have
free time on my hands and I'd like to I
would like to come out there and let's
get dinner
he goes on to say what I can feel is
that I do have your heart and that is
all I need just in these past days you
have made me sore and we have not even
spoken on the phone and I already feel
more complete with you back in my life
seems we both have had to take our
journey separated from each other only
to find ourselves coming back together
again
seems so sweet Until you realize how
horrifying this is let me talk about it
right now with my co-host Brian
buckmeyer Terry Austin great to see you
both Terry I'll start with you we got a
cold-blooded murder here or we have
something maybe like a crime of passion
where do you land on it well initially
it does seem like it's a cold-blooded
murder he's driving 11 hours a lot of
time to think about that people may
think it's premeditated but he might
have been manipulated which is what they
are saying and it could be that it was a
crime of passion or Jesse it could even
be that he was there defending her
because he thought she was going to be
harmed she was claiming that her husband
Jamie was harming her and so he's there
to help her out we were talking about
that the problem with that Brian is
imminent right it's not like he was
about to stab her about to punch her
about the shooter how do you argue
self-defense in that case well the
argument I think there is what was the
harm that she told him she was suffering
it was not just physical it was also
emotional abuse and so the concept would
be there that the imminency is that she
is always in a state of abuse his
presence is a form of abuse so if he's
walking down the street to the home the
grocery store whoever may be and his
temper flips then she could be
imminently facing that that abuse and
that harm or she could be hearing that
just emotional abuse would be him being
presents does that ever work though
someone's in a constant state of fear
for their life and someone could come in
and they might have a manipulated
version of events I mean is that have
you ever seen that work I've seen it
work when you have a woman woman who is
claiming that all of this time she's
been with someone and he's been abusing
a battered syndrome exactly but I
haven't seen it where you have another
person a hired person a third person who
is protecting that battered woman do you
think the jury could just come back and
look at it as a sympathy vote and say we
feel really bad for him maybe forget the
law it could be well it could be but to
Terry's Point even though we've seen it
with women in intimate partner violence
the same apartment the same type of
self-defense that the person could do
for themselves a third person can do as
well so arguably you should be able to
do it if someone can do it for
themselves well I'll tell you what we
have more to talk about this because
still ahead on Long crime daily our
coverage of the Darren Ruben Lopez trial
will not stop here we're going to be
digging into experiences of people
outside this couple's strange
relationship and that they had with them
this could all help point to the idea
that Lopez was in fact manipulated
that's next
foreign
daily everybody so we're discussing the
trial of Darren Rubin Lopez this is the
man accused of killing his girlfriend's
husband so that they could be together
remember Jennifer faith is serving life
in prison after she entered a guilty
plea to a federal murder for higher
charge authorities say that she
convinced Reuben Lopez that her husband
James was physically and sexually
abusing her Jennifer admitted at her
sentencing that she manipulated Ruben
Lopez who suffered from a traumatic
brain injury and also PTSD after serving
in the Army in Iraq and the two had been
having a long distance Affair for months
when he apparently drove from Tennessee
to Texas to shoot James the neighbor who
heard the shots and ran out of his house
says he feels betrayed now that he knows
that Jennifer was faking her grief the
whole time
now we know though that he knew exactly
who it was right
yes sir and how does that make you feel
make me feel I mean
disappointed
that I I wasted I pretty much wasted my
time trying to help someone that
was using me
she was using your good nature as a
neighbor
I think more or less you just use
everybody
you think that helps Brian he was
manipulated he was tricked the defendant
was manipulated defendant was tricked I
uh I think I snapped you
no
I I think it helps both sides depending
on how you manipulate it I'm still on
the point of why do the defense let that
come in no one cares about how you feel
after the fact if that was allowed in
testimony for trials everyone could
testify about how a defendant made them
feel based on their interactions after
the fact he's not relevant to the crime
but I think either side could use it and
say look she manipulates like she
manipulated this guy she manipulated
Lopez everyone fell for it why are you
punishing this guy and for the
prosecution I think it works less for
them I don't actually don't know why
they walk down that path you think it
should have been allowed in that
testimony definitely not but you didn't
hear an objection and if you don't get
an objection the judge is not going to
on his own side listen this testimony
shouldn't be in because it's not
relevant like Brian said it was after
the fact just because this neighbor felt
as though he was manipulated has nothing
to do with whether or not she actually
committed this crime now I do think the
defense is doing a great job the fact
that he found this witness and he was
allowed to put this testimony in he's
doing everything he can for his client
to make his client look as though he's
innocent and that the other person that
Jennifer she's the one who started all
of this she's the one who did the
manipulation and by the way at some
point you're going to find out she's
serving time for this so let me ask you
this is the intent a good I use that
word maybe to show that he didn't have
the intent to
premeditate on this to deliberate to
kill maybe they're trying to lessen it
to something like manslaughter is that
an option here I think that's hard that
drive from Texas to Tennessee is it's
tough right along I think what my
American geography is not the worst I am
Canadian so yeah he's as an excuse but
you got to go through Arkansas from what
I understand that's really going to hurt
you for a premeditation argument I think
you say he didn't he was manipulated and
the facts before him suggest more
self-defense or defense of others than a
cold-blooded killer but he is different
because you can't just say oh
everybody's gonna argue PTSD to get out
of things he might be unique no yeah I
think he also is suffering I don't know
what the medical records are we'll see
if we get any of that but the defense
counsel did say during opening it's all
documented so the jury is going to be
able to understand that he definitely
isn't operating the way other people
operate because he has a very serious
PTSD syndrome very different case you
remember the Gypsy Rose Blanchard case
when she was accused of manipulating her
online boyfriend to do to kill her
mother correct it's kind of have slavors
of it of that as well